And this is actually the historic and of the Spanish civil war.
Um,
obviously,
um,
the Republicans lost,
uh,
they wanted to losing sight and,
um,
the winner gets to appear on the cover of Time magazine.
Um,
March 27,
1939 general Franco,
um,
there.
So,
um,
even though,
it actually ended a little slightly later than that,
but already at that point it was clear that there was no way,
um,
the fascist would not win.
So that's why he was on the cover of Time magazine.
Um,
so,
but what we are looking at obviously is a some time before that when things are
still,
um,
basically up in the air.
Um,
and so when,
when we get to the end of the film developed holes,
Ashley,
there's still hope for Robyn in many ways.
Um,
and so we'll be looking at that at the end of today's lecture.
But I also want to call your attention to a very interesting fat,
um,
about the Spanish civil war,
uh,
which is that it was very much,
a women's war.
Um,
one of the,
unlike world war one or in the world war two,
where there weren't a lot of women doing the actual fighting,
um,
the spend,
this whole world was one that was very proud of the fact that,
um,
there,
that women were participating,
um,
in,
in a fairly significant way.
So we can see that both in the posters,
um,
celebrating that fact.
Um,
but also in,
yeah,
in numerous,
um,
picked photos that we have a of women at either training or actually in combat
situations.
So that's just one of them.
Um,
they were trained just as a man would be trained,
um,
and they were in uniform.
Um,
and this,
uh,
where the,
women,
Alicia from Barcelona I think,
and once more,
um,
more women are fighting.
So,
you know,
partly I think that accounts for feather pillows is such a powerful figure in
for whom the bell tolls.
That this is one of the few Hemingway novel was where,
um,
there's a fairly strong,
a woman's voice.
We,
my thing that maybe she's too good to be true of that maybe is overly idealized,
but in any case,
pillows with,
um,
rare instance of a very powerful woman who would dare to,
cast adjustment Paskel judgment,
um,
on the conduct of her own site.
You know,
when she was thought that the revolution had begun badly,
as we saw last time,
a woman who's not afraid to have that opinion.
Um,
so partly had to do with the fact that the women were so important,
um,
in the Spanish civil war as soldiers.
Um,
but I think that it also has something to do with the personal circumstances and
Hemingway's own live.
Um,
if you turn to the friend of the for whom the bell tolls,
you'll see that is dedicated to Martha Gellhorn,
um,
who,
uh,
Hemingway was married to Martha Gellhorn.
Um,
then when they were writing,
when they were covering the Spanish civil war.
Um,
and she very much was very important.
Journal is on her own right.
So,
um,
this is the book that she wrote,
uh,
both about the Spanish civil war,
but also about World War II.
Um,
and,
um,
about,
in fact about Vietnam,
um,
when all the way to the six days.
Um,
so she really hadn't very long and distinguished career as a war journalist and,
um,
in recognition of the fact that as we was to the United States Post [inaudible]
stamp celebrating her writing,
uh,
with her wartime writings from Japan,
China,
this right.
Uh,
the Chinese revolution was very important part,
however,
writing,
um,
and the Normandy and Darko,
the World War II episodes.
Um,
so,
uh,
I was tempted actually to read some of her writing,
but there's just no room to incorporate her wartime reporting into this class.
But I just want to draw your attention to the fact that she was actually a very,
um,
significant companion to Hemingway,
in more ways than one.
So today we'll be talking about,
um,
basically the narrative form of Hemingway and you guys will be getting people
topics,
um,
very soon from your,
uh,
teaching fellows and one of the topics,
um,
we'll have to do with forms of narration.
Then they're just structured.
So I want to start talking about that and to get you guys thinking,
um,
about,
various experimental or a well rehearsed,
but nonetheless,
um,
still,
reinvigorated forms in this novel.
Um,
so we'll,
we'll be looking at questions with symmetry and the mirror effect that already
we're seeing a little bit off.
Right.
Um,
last time we talked about the kind of negative mirroring the earth moving for
Robert Jordan and um,
Maria when they made love and that being mirrored negatively with the bombing
when the earth move under the feet of the people who were bombed.
Um,
so that's one instance of a kind of negative symmetry.
something being iron eyes.
Uh,
retroactively today we'll be looking at more instances of those kinds of
symmetries.
Um,
so obviously possession and have and have not a longstanding,
uh,
paradigm that we've been looking at.
Ironic and not ironic.
Um,
and then also ending the beginning,
very important and this novel.
But I want to begin by looking at one particular assymetry,
uh,
which is the symmetry of brutality,
of brutal conduct.
Um,
execution that we saw,
the execution of the fascist that we saw last time in chapter 10.
Um,
and then in chapter 31,
um,
is similar,
maybe a more horrendous episode of fashions,
violence,
the rape that inflicted on Maria.
Um,
so it really goes back also to the importance of women in the Spanish civil war
as well.
Um,
and because rape is such a,
um,
kind of explosive subject,
there's been lost done on rape.
This is Susan Brown Miller's again.
So it,
one of the classic considerations of rape.
Um,
they also has been lost in lots of representation of rape in painting,
um,
and especially rape consider as a matter for,
for,
uh,
the brutalities,
perpetrated on the defeated by the victories.
So,
you know,
even though it's the women who are getting raped,
um,
it really is a kind of a mother for,
for,
uh,
what happens to the loser in war.
Um,
so Pusan actually had a number of paintings.
I don't even,
I can't even keep count as the significant number.
Um,
this is one,
and this is,
um,
and the other one at Duluth,
very well known painting.
Um,
it can get monotonous after awhile.
I mean they,
they are different,
but they also quite difficult like,
um,
so when,
Picasso,
um,
came to redoing this theme,
you can see that this is real,
um,
new departure.
It looks nothing like the prison paintings.
Um,
and so that is the sort of the 20th century take,
um,
uh,
ferry a time honored theme.
And I would argue that Hemingway is in his own way doing a novelistic rendition
of the rape of this have been women in the rape of just one particular woman,
Maria.
Um,
and I would argue that it is every bit as innovative as to Picasso painting
coming out at the same time,
a complete departure from tradition.
Um,
so it was innovative about Hemingway and it actually goes back to his lungs,
standing interest in the mirror,
um,
at,
and looking at yourself in the mirror.
We last time you saw that when Robert was dropping the gun,
uh,
the Pisco that was misused by his father,
he was looking at himself,
his mirror image in the water,
looking at himself,
holding the gun and then dropping the gun.
So we've really seen one instance of the mirror and for about host,
and this is a much more traumatic instance of that.
I saw my face in the mirror of the barbershop and the faces of three others who
were leaning over me.
And I knew none of the phases,
but in the glass I saw myself and them,
but they saw only me and it was as though one,
we're in the dentist chair and there were many dentists and they were all in
saying my own face.
I could hardly recognize because my grief had changed it.
But I looked at it and knew that it was me,
but my grief was so great that I had no fear,
no any feeling.
But my grief.
So this is the beginning.
This is not actually the ripe is just cutting off her hair.
Um,
in many ways,
uh,
innocuous exercise.
But the rate would come after that.
Mra doesn't talk about the actual rape.
So this is all as close as we can get is the looking at herself in the mirror.
Um,
and I think that it is,
um,
uh,
kind of a belated,
um,
rejoinder to the earlier episodes of Robert Looking at his own face in the
water,
um,
in the sense that this is,
associated with trauma for,
for some reason,
um,
to look at oneself in the mirror is,
is it's kind of a traumatic tableau for Hemingway is the precondition for some
kind of trauma.
Um,
in the case of the earlier episode with Robert Looking at himself in mirrored in
a water,
it's actually the beginning of a cleansing process.
He is ridding himself of that pistol that he would want to have nothing to do
with.
Um,
in this case,
Maria,
looking at herself in the mirror as the rape is about to happen is the beginning
of the trauma.
So let's look at the visual tableau that Hemingway is creating for us because of
the optics,
this particular optics of their scene.
Um,
Maria can see herself.
and then the three of them,
and they can look at the mirror and they see only Maria.
So this is a great example of how self consciousness is.
Um,
in many ways,
uh,
the burden of the person who is tortured on the,
put the people who are doing latoya torturing,
um,
see only the object of the torture.
So they get all the pleasure from being able to inflict maximum damage,
um,
gone on the person that they are during.
They don't see themselves doing it.
That's what enables them to do it is that they don't see themselves.
Um,
Maria sees herself and she sees the street people who are able to do this,
um,
for her.
Um,
and what we're beginning to see is in many ways the beginning of the process of
this procession,
Maria looks at herself,
but because of those three looming figures behind her already,
she's not quite herself.
She is herself plus those three other people.
And she's also not quite herself because,
um,
they're cutting off her hair.
So she's losing very important part of her identity.
So it was just beginning not to recognize herself.
And,
um,
this process of wrecking not recognizing herself would get dramatize.
Um,
in a way that goes back actually to the image.
We have two lines that we had talked about in that Robert Motherwell also,
uh,
um,
represented in numerous paintings,
the to all the late lines that,
um,
would be the Utopian ideal,
uh,
of,
um,
of political ritual in the execution of the fascist.
In this case.
Um,
it is once again a retroactive RNI station of that earlier utopian moment.
We get the same two lines except that those two lines have now have a completely
different meaning.
At that time.
I wore my hair in two braids and I watch it in the mirror.
One of them lifted one of the brace and pulled on it so it hurts me suddenly
through my grief and then cut it off close to my head with eraser.
And I saw myself with one grade and a slash where the other had been that he cut
off the other gray.
But without pulling on it and the razor and made a small cut on my ear and I saw
blood come from it can start a few.
The scar for life with Dai Finger.
Yes,
but will they be bad enough to talk about this?
This is nothing.
I will not talk of that,
which is bad.
So he had cut both brace close to my head with a razor and the others laugh and
I did not even feel the cuddle my ear.
And then he stood in front of me and striped one across the phase and struck me
across the face with a brace while the other two held me.
And he said,
this is how we make red nuns.
This will show the,
how do you night with that approach?
Hereon brothers,
Bri of the red Christ.
And he struck me again and again across the face with a brace which had been
mined.
And then he put the two of them in my mouth and tie them tight around my neck,
nodding them in the back to make a gag.
And the two holding me laugh.
So this is the new use to which lines could be put the tube raise,
belonging to oneself,
um,
can be used as weapons against oneself.
So this is very much the same logic as the earth rising up and hitting the man
that,
uh,
that has been our coaching up to this point and uh,
that is,
um,
so is,
is,
is really the complete reversal of the meaning of something,
um,
that really is supportive of you and the radical alienation,
of that thing.
Um,
and the instrument instruments to elevation of that thing into a weapon.
but even then,
I think it's less traumatic than the effect of looking at the mirror and
watching yourself losing first one braid and then the other,
and then watching the transformation,
um,
of your face when that is happening.
Um,
it is not only inflicting that on Maria,
but also making her watch herself undergo this transformation that's just
becoming an alien being even two eyes.
Um,
so this is the final,
this is the conclusion of that act of dispossession.
Then the one who had gag Mary ran a clipper over my head.
First of all,
the foreign,
all the way to the back of the neck and then across the top and then over my
head and close behind my ears and they help me.
So I could see into the glass with a Bob was mirror all the time that they did
is,
and I could not believe it as I saw it done and I cried and cried.
But I could not look away from the horror than my face made with the mouth open
and the braised tied in it and my head coming naked under the clippers.
Um,
so this is the closest that hemming we'll,
we'll get to,
um,
giving us an image of Maria being rendered completely defenseless because all
the things,
the shelter ourselves are being taken away from her.
Um,
hair might not be the most powerful form of shelter,
um,
but it is,
a form of shelter in the sense that without it,
we really look very negative.
They get in a kind of psychological sense.
Um,
and Maria will be,
will become naked and more than that sense.
Um,
but it has also has to do with,
uh,
what kinds of an object Maria would be in the world before this happens.
She would never be an object to herself,
should always be a subject to himself in the sense that she would never actually
see herself as she's seeing herself right now.
So it is really taking away her relation to herself that is being taken away
from her.
It's not even just the hair,
you know,
which is nothing and then will grow back.
Although we can also see the Hemingways quite obsessed with hair and the cutting
off of hair,
um,
just as,
uh,
Fitzgerald is in Bernie's cuts her hair.
Um,
but the physical removal of the hair is really nothing,
um,
compare with the destruction of a longstanding relationship that one has to
oneself.
And I think that we see a similar operation,
um,
when it is w w when someone within [inaudible],
uh,
to a point where you don't actually recognize the person who has been in Saudi.
It might not ever have happened to you.
And very rarely it happens to anyone.
Um,
but certain new hurst and talks about that in an essay called how I became the
college me,
uh,
was that when she was growing up,
um,
in the black community in Florida,
the,
she never saw herself as black until she was made to feel herself as
Blackstone's losing one kind of identity to oneself.
And what is happening here is a similar kind of situation that suddenly she sees
herself as something that she's never seen herself as before.
So it is both that operation,
but also the additional horror that she cannot take her eyes away from the Mira.
She could easily have shut her eyes.
Right.
So the psychological atrocity of this thing is that the dynamics of the scene is
such that she cannot take her ways to take the eyes away from this thing that
she cannot bear to watch.
Um,
it is,
they're gluing of her eyes to something that she would want to do,
everything to remove the eyes drowned.
It is that gluing,
um,
that is also plugged in.
[inaudible] um,
so it is,
it is,
it is the way the Hemingway chooses.
Talk about rape,
not,
um,
they're very completely recognizable and scenario that Pusan has made classic,
you know,
in his classic compositions.
Um,
and not even the Picasso Representation,
um,
which still has to do much more with someone crying out in protest.
We can almost hear the song in the Picasso representation in the Murray you
episodes.
There is absolutely no song because her mouth has been gap.
So is the absolute silencing of Maria.
And the complete reduction of that scenario into a visual scenario without sung
in both the Pusan and in the Picasso Painting,
what makes it slightly bearable is that we can imagine those women as crying
out.
Um,
and it is that crying out that makes them human and registers the resistance to
whether it's being done to them.
In the case of Maria,
because is strictly a mirror if I,
and because it is strictly visual tableau and he goes a mile,
this gap,
it is completely songs.
So it is the deprivation of voice,
um,
along with the cutting of the hair.
Um,
is those two things that work to create the maximum effect of victimization in
the rape scenes.
So we can see that from Maria.
This possession,
um,
is a central narrative fat and it is register with food.
Matter of fact,
um,
as unforgettable an instance of rape has any,
in American literature with actually representing the APP itself.
Um,
so that is part of the innovation as well as that you don't actually go anywhere
near the actual deed.
Um,
given the fact that this possession is so important from a rear,
I think that we have to ask a related question is to what extent is this
procession central for Robert?
Um,
I think it is an open question.
I hope that you guys would talk about it in section is whether or not Maria
Ashley gets to recover from that act of,
uh,
of,
of this possession.
Um,
has she recovered fully from that rape or is she still living in the shadow of
that rape?
How long does it take for that shadow to go away?
Uh,
is she's still within the narrative of dispossession all the way through for
whom the bell tolls?
So there's an open question for Maria for Robert.
Um,
it's a slightly different question and it has to do with two possible
trajectories for Robert.
Um,
and so what I would like to do here is to give you a demonstration of one way to
write your final paper,
um,
which is to write half of the paper as dedicated to one argument and the other
half as dedicated to the opposite argument.
So this is,
uh,
would be an interesting experiment to do.
Basically you're trying to be a lawyer,
right?
Lawyers are supposed to argue either side of the case.
Um,
you know,
is an intellectual exercise.
Um,
usually it takes,
for most of us,
it takes a loan from Wellington at that we actually have,
they have some kind of emotional investment in something,
uh,
to,
argue to make it very convincing case.
But supposedly someone who's trained as a lawyer should be able to argue either
side.
So when I'm asked,
offering you as one possibility,
um,
in the final paper is to,
make an argument,
um,
one way and then in exactly the opposite way.
Um,
and in this case is not even a stretch for me to argue both sides of the case
because actually on completely torn in my mind.
So actually there is emotional investment on my iPod in both sides of the
argument.
So,
um,
the two opposing arguments,
obviously would be,
one would be,
uh,
that to happen,
for whom the bell tolls,
uh,
is a narrative about this procession that what work Robert ends up with at the
end of the novel is as a half,
not that he starts out with something,
um,
and then ballet and the novel where everything is taken away from him,
that he is completely empty handed at the ends enough.
Um,
the very hush reading after novel.
The other,
um,
and I like to end with that is to argue that it actually is a narrative of
repossession.
Ah,
yes,
that a lot has been taken away from him,
but that may be we could still make a case that he's not totally empty handed at
the end of the novel.
So I like to,
I hope I'll be able to make a compelling case for both.
Uh,
but let's start with a trajectory one.
And,
um,
obviously in order to make a case for Robert as a half,
not,
I think that we have to put an ironic spin on the word to have,
um,
especially on a memorable line.
Roberto,
what has now,
um,
and I want to bring back Ashley to a similar use.
Ironic use of the word half in as I lay dying.
Um,
and following from that,
we can look at a narrative structure of for him about hoes and look at it as a
kind of a narrative and that when in terms of the formal structure of the novel
as the narrative and Admin of the APP of dispossession,
that Robert is losing control of the narrative that an arm and the lake has been
cut off from him and taken over by someone else.
And comparing that with maybe a kind of a similar situation into half and half,
not,
um,
so first to have as an ironic word,
this is at the very end of the novel,
Maria was kneeling by him and saying,
Roberto,
what has,
now he says,
wedding heavily.
The left leg is broken.
Guava,
the swears street priestly phase bend down by him.
And Robert Jordan smelled the full smell of Pablo.
Let us speak his head too polite in Maria.
I have to speak to them.
How the,
there's a hope much but doesn't hurt much problems as he was banned in clothes
over Robert Jordan.
No,
I think the nerve is crash.
Listen,
get along and to say I would talk to the girl for a moment.
Clearly there's not much time.
Clearly I think you would do better in the rebel.
They'd probably chosen said they unseal graders.
Use your head,
talk to the now policies that there is little time.
I'm sorry Dow has this English since I have it.
Proper choice that does not speak of it but used,
I had dow has too much had um,
it is very hard to not to know this,
the way that the key player in this passage is the verb to have.
Um,
it begins with Maria asking Robert Innocence mate,
what has now,
because in class she doesn't know whether the legacy really broken.
Um,
but he knows.
so,
um,
and is at this point is the switching of Pablo for Maria.
Um,
Beth for me is,
represents one of the cruel decisions on Hemingway's pot,
um,
that instead of having Maria still bending over him,
the person who is now banned over Robert is Pablo and what he smells is to full
smell of Pablo.
This a very,
very significant sees hell.
Um,
in the sense that rob is still doesn't really know Pablo,
he remained remains a mysterious figure.
Um,
all the way through.
I mentioned last time that a lot of things happen.
Um,
Pablo does a lot of things.
He things,
lots of things when we're not privy to what is going on in the narrative.
Um,
and likewise for Robert,
he simply doesn't know what's going on inside problems head or what public is
doing is executing other people when Robert isn't looking.
So all of this,
because it's bad might be happening,
but we just never know.
Um,
so Pablo is,
is,
is from beginning to end.
His always,
and they'll pay character,
both Robert and to us.
But all that Robert can get at this moment is to first smell of Pablo.
That that is,
is the overwhelming older,
almost like the smell of honeysuckle that is coming to Robin at the end of his
life.
Um,
that is about the most that he can,
that he will ever get is not as cerebral understanding.
Uh,
uh,
Pablo is just an animal apprehension of how powerful a man this is,
smells and animal says,
I think it's the animals fear and apprehension but also recognition.
What kind of a Pablo is.
Um,
so Pablo asked innocently enough question,
how does it hurt much?
Um,
but he knows that there's no way Robert can travel this no way he can go with
the rest of the people.
So,
um,
that's,
he knows politically well how much time really is left to rob it.
Um,
and there is,
um,
been
upfront,
cruelly I think,
um,
in the last thing that Pablo says to,
uh,
Robert,
I'm sorry,
doubt has this English from beginning to end,
the refusal recognition,
the robber this American and not English,
that he has a name even,
um,
you know,
he for Pablo,
Robert is just like Haskins.
Some of the ranting who comes in,
who destroys the bridge,
destroy something works the explosive is killed his,
another of those,
a whole string of foreigners coming through with totally forgettable names and
not even getting the nationality right.
So this is the ultimate in,
um,
inflicted by Pablo on Robert at the very end of his life.
And Rob is absolutely defenseless.
You know,
he is defenseless,
physically is defenseless psychologically and emotionally.
Um,
all he can say,
um,
is in fact this the mission of defeat really,
giving the last bit of advice,
telling Pablo to go back,
they have behind the enemy lines,
right?
So they are internationally and fashions and nationalist territory and he
advises probably to go back to the Spanish republic.
But Pablo says,
no,
I'm actually go to go further away from the Spanish republic.
Um,
I'm four graders.
And actually that turns out to be really smart decision because if they had gone
back to the Spanish republic,
they would actually all had been killed.
So Robert is actually right to end with the last line.
Dow has much had,
um,
the cemetery here is betraying Robert having a broken leg and Harborough having
much head.
He's the brainy one.
This is the ultimate rewriting of the power dynamics and for whom the bell
tolls.
We've been going along the assumption that is the person with the knowledge or
the technology,
the person with the knowledge of the world,
the person who can speak several languages.
We've been going on the assumption that that person is going to be on top,
that you know,
he's the future belongs to him.
The irony,
ultimate irony of this novel is in fact,
this is the person who's going to lose out,
who will have no future at all.
So in many ways we can either say it is a very brutal undoing of everything
that,
uh,
Robert is believed in.
All we can say.
You know,
it actually is a kind of inverted Utopian Vision,
um,
that there is still a future for the Spanish hasn't,
even though they seem so disadvantage in the modern world,
um,
even though they seem completely incapable of functioning outside of the very
limited environment,
um,
because they are capable of functioning within that very limited environment,
actually they have a chance to survive at least as to narrative that,
uh,
that the Hemingway is giving us.
Um,
so,
uh,
kind of negative utopia for Robert and positive utopia for Pablo.
Um,
and it is ironic but I don't think that it actually is,
it's fully ironic that Pablo should be the embodiment of some kind of utopian
hope at the end of the novel.
Um,
and just to give you a kind of a comparison point of comparison for similar use
of the verb to be in SLA dying almost exactly the same.
Um,
cash has a broken leg.
He has had two broken legs.
He lies on the box with a quilt road onto his head and the piece of wood under
his knee,
I reckon we ought to left him at arms days past that.
I haven't gotten a broken leg and power hasn't,
and Dow has an and it's just the bums caches.
It's kind of grinds to get a little on the bone.
It don't bother.
So exactly.
Hemingway and Fitzgerald had the same intuition about the extent to which the
work to have can be Aaronow's.
Um,
so given the fact that Robert is well on his way,
well,
I mean now they fit well on his way.
He's arrived at his definition destination,
uh,
which is the state of this possession at the end of the novel.
Uh,
we should not be surprised that,
um,
that destination is well prepared for,
some ways before that.
Um,
so I just want to call your attention to a narrative innovation and for whom and
about hose,
uh,
which is the removal of the narrative from Robert Jordan.
He doesn't get to tell the story right there.
Four chapters,
um,
told by someone else.
Um,
quite literally cutting off the narrative from Robert and those four chapters
are the chapters when Andres who is charged with a mission to go and deliver
this very important message,
um,
to the central command that um,
the,
the um,
that,
that they're actually the enemy knew what they were going to launch this attack.
That very important information that was going to be conveyed by Andres is toe
in full chapters that have nothing.
Absolutely nothing to do with Robert.
So let me just give you one instance of that removal of the narrative from
Robert Chapter fully.
He's a non protagonists is a non participant.
He doesn't show up at all in that chapter during the time that Robert Jordan has
labs through the time he has spent planning the destruction of the bridge and
the time that he had been with Maria Andres had made slow progress until he
reached the Republican minds.
He had traveled across country and through the fascist lines as fast as a
countryman in good physical condition.
Who knew the country well could travel in the dark,
but what is the insides Republican lines,
it,
whatever it is,
slowly.
Um,
so this are the right here that we detect,
um,
that uh,
for Andres,
I mean this is very dramatic because actually it takes so much,
much more time to try to get through supposedly your own side because he's
questioned detained by everyone.
Uh,
whereas it's much faster to go through enemy terrain because it's just traveling
as someone who is physically fit can travel,
which is very fast.
Um,
so those four chapters,
um,
34,
36,
40 and 42,
those four chapters are devoted to the irony of how slow it is for and how
impossible it is,
uh,
for Andres to deliver that crucial message.
Um,
but the other additional RNA is that Robert is fast becoming a non protagonists
in his own narrative,
which is framed much a prelude to the end at the end of whom the bell hose,
he will be a non player in the future of the Spanish republic.
He will be a non player in Maria's life in Pablo was laughing,
everyone's loved.
Um,
and Hemingway has ran a pays to way for Robert being a non player much earlier.
So we can think back to many other instances of someone being a non player in
soldiers home in,
in our time.
Uh,
crabs being a non play,
his sister pay,
playing basketball,
um,
and he crafts being on the Cylon it being a non plane that went.
So Hemingway's has given a lot of thought for what it means for a man who once
used to be a important player to be relegated to the silence and to suffer the
fate of being a non player.
And he is enacting that one more time.
Um,
in foamed about hose.
So,
um,
I just want to um,
highlight the interconnections about Hemingway's works.
This is not the first time where he has removed the narrative from the
supposedly protagonism that narrative and to have and have not a similar fate
has been visited upon herring Morgan.
Right?
So in chapters one to five toe from Harry Morgan's point of view chapters,
things all of a sudden his refer to you as a man,
you ain't going to fix me out.
And they go say the man whose name was Harry Morgan,
send nothing then because he liked the nigger and there was nothing to do now.
But here then what,
you know,
when we were talking about this passage,
we said that suddenly Harry becomes Harry Morgan.
Um,
some are looked at completely from the outside and who is in fact put in the
same position as the black person did have both lost something.
Um,
and in a more abstract way we can say that what Robert,
um,
and we can also just go back to that moment at the very end of,
for him and about those,
Robert is still Robert Jordan.
He never gets to the stage where you can simply be a Robert.
He is still referred to in that alienating form.
Um,
so that too is a similar structure with very much similar to the alienating
device in to have and have nots.
I think that I've done,
um,
you know,
my power,
everything that I can,
um,
to make a case for,
to have and have not as a novel of this procession,
um,
that basically,
uh,
Robert Emerges as completely empty handed,
at the end of the [inaudible] that he's lost his leg,
his lost Maria is loss of life is about to lose his life is lost.
Even a novel that is supposedly is.
So it is a loss almost completely equal to the laws of Dow at the end of as I
lay dying.
Um,
and it really is possible to read both Hemingway and partner,
um,
as others who are dedicated to about the bleeders vision possible of human
possibilities.
Um,
but I want to,
um,
now make the opposite case,
uh,
which is then,
it's not quite as bleak as that.
There may be this one way in which we can think about before we have to have as
a somewhat non ironic,
uh,
word.
So,
um,
and,
and also that there's a way to read the narrative,
um,
not as one that highlights or maybe passes the,
the absolute Danning worthy that there really is nothing at the end for Robert.
Um,
so trying to recover something for Robert at the end,
the narrative.
Um,
so,
um,
it turns out that Hemingway is also a kind of self conscious about using the
verb to have as unknown.
Ironic for,
uh,
this is a little earlier so you know,
it has the disadvantage of coming before that final,
very ironic moment and,
but still is a moment that we should look at.
And another thing,
don't have a kid yourself about loving someone is just the most people are not
lucky enough ever to have it.
You never had it before and now you haven't or you have with Maria,
whether it lasts just through today and the positive tomorrow or whether it
lasts for a long time is the most important thing that can happen to a human
being.
There will always be people who say it does not exist because they cannot have
it.
But I tell you,
it is true that you have it and that you are lucky even if you die tomorrow.
Um,
so you know,
this is,
uh,
this is relatively speaking,
an instance where we have to verb to have in an IRA an ironic non erotic mold,
um,
that is affirming,
the primacy and the durability of what he had or has or continue to have with
Maria.
Um,
but we also know that even in this non ironic moment,
the verb to have is very precarious.
Um,
it is precarious because there's so much dependent on being able to refute other
people who would not credit you with having that thing.
Right.
So there's this consciousness that there will always be people who say that does
not exist because they cannot have it.
Because what you have here,
what Robin has here is so intangible because there's really no material way to
demonstrate it.
It is,
there is simply is not an object.
It's not a physical object in the world.
Um,
there's no evidence really.
There's no material evidence,
um,
that it is a thing in the world.
Um,
all you have is your subjective intuition that you did have it,
that you continue to have it.
Um,
and then having it makes all the difference.
It is only a subjective conviction.
It doesn't carry the weight of objective demonstrate ability.
Um,
and so that is one strike against it.
That other people will not be persuaded by the fact that you did have it.
They,
we continue to tell you that you didn't.
Um,
the other thing which I thing is it actually plays out in a kind of formal level
has to do with a switch of pronouns in this passage,
right?
So it begins with,
um,
but actually all the way through this passage,
the pronoun has array of switch.
Um,
even though Robert has been referring to it has been just talking in the first
person singular.
I,
um,
in this critical moment he's actually referring to himself as you,
you never had it before and now you have it.
And even more powerfully in the last line where you see both the Pronoun I and
approved now you.
But I tell you,
it is true that you have it and that you are lucky.
Even if you died tomorrow,
the coal presence of the Pronoun I and the Pronoun you suggest that it is an
effort it takes them will power to convince himself that he did have it.
I am telling you that you did have it.
It's not just the other people are not persuaded,
but Robert himself has to be convinced is to be beaten over the head about his
other eye.
Um,
to believe that yes,
that what he did have with Maria does make a difference and that's make him
half.
So because of those two considerations,
I would say that this is um,
the non,
I use of the word to have but heavily slogans,
right?
Uh,
with other policies is really looming heavily on the horizon.
Um,
and um,
the is flow replayed in the very last moment,
often novel.
He looked down the hill slope again and he thought,
I hate to leave it as all I hate who live in very much and I hope that I have
done some good in it.
I would try to with what talent I had half you mean?
All right,
have I have fourth of what I believe in for a year.
Now if we win here,
we will win everywhere.
The world's a fine place and worth fighting for and I hate very much to leave
it.
And you have a lot of luck.
He told himself to have had such a good life.
You've had just as good as alive.
His grandfather don't,
not as long.
You've had just as good a life as anyone because of these last days.
So once again,
non ironic use of those love to have but ticking an effort of the will to
convince himself he has to be toe youth had a good life as your grandfather.
You've had as good alive as anyone.
Um,
it has to be a command issue by father himself.
and so it takes that form that it is not,
um,
is not,
is not a a natural or unselfconscious.
A conviction is a conviction,
arrive at through some struggle and we've put a good effort.
Um,
so,
um,
Robert,
that thing is,
is it's actually a fairy,
um,
the fragile vehicle,
as,
as a representative of a kind of narrative of repossession just because he's so
vulnerable at the end of the novel.
Um,
but I think that that Hemingway actually has stepped in and provided one form of
authorial intervention that allows us,
um,
possibly to read the novel as affirming something about Robert so that he's not
totally a loser at the end of novel.
Um,
and that has to do with a very stylized ferry,
a deliberate narrative structure for whom the bell tolls.
Uh,
you know,
there's the,
the first line of the novel reads,
he lay flat on the bra pine needle floor,
the forest,
his chin on his throat and arms and high overhead to win two in the top of the
pine trees.
And the very last line of the novel,
he could feel his heart beating against the pine needle store,
the forests.
So Robert totally alone,
but in the end is the beginning.
Um,
and so it is that impersonal narrative structure.
the,
he's not that,
it's almost as if he were beginning all over again,
that the story is going to begin the new,
um,
it is that formal structure,
the former mirror,
the fact that allows us to entertain the illusion that not ours over here and
the Hoe in Ho,
you know,
the physical it is over,
um,
that no way it could have a different ending or that things could go on.
But nonetheless,
the form of the narrative is such,
if feels like the beginning rather than the ad.
Um,
and maybe this is really the best that Hemingway can do for Robin,
is for the reader to want this to be a new beginning and for the reader to feel
that this isn't the ad yet.
This is the best that we can do.
The robbery.